what's up brandon it's owen here in
bangor north wales uk
gang god bless you welcome guaranty i'll
sing it for you
those seats for the dead there's in
memoriam hitters
do you want them would you have them
when you're gone do you want someone
parking their ass and your dead name
uh this one's for phyllis dole phyllis
dole
rest in peace phyllis
what's up ceo what's up stole rest in
peace phyllis
so uh yeah let me know king ought to
sting it those in memoriam seats
gang gang buzz buzz i love this guy
what's his name
all right what's up theo what's up
brandon it's owen here i'm back
owen oh who's well's jack as well isn't
he uh jack shore yeah he's just sure as
well
darren tales from liverpool yeah yeah
yeah yeah and darren title want this
[ __ ] smoke boy
miami [ __ ] what 190 is that fair dude
i'll meet him at 100 dog i'll chop both
my arms and legs off dog
hell yeah bro i'll bite his [ __ ] anus
open hell yeah
no homo bro no but nah man they're both
legends
um but yeah in memoriam seats
do you want that when you're gone some
big fat seat where people sit
um or some wheelchair ramp nah build a
statue man
do something cool let me look man love
you
but also nobody no it's no statue
nobody's building us a statue of you my
girl could do it on our front lawn
like i'm walt disney [ __ ] yeah there's
one of nick right
yeah look nick why can't i
oh now we can do something like that for
you guys right here
okay look yeah we gotta be carrying
tacos i don't need it big
oh okay just dip that [ __ ] in gold
we'll call it even we could do something
small yeah yeah all right we could do
something that would be honestly
you're thinking of the big like michael
jackson stuff no come on now
i know where i'm at okay i think if we
do something that could be on a key ring
or something yeah
but you smash produce them okay so yeah
we could do something like that man
name a street after me yeah you could do
that but if you live out in the country
you can do that yourself
no i don't want some [ __ ] street
like rename abbott kenny
rename main street i'll take it mlk
street
whatever you want to do but they're not
going to do that man i mean they might
but they're not
you never know i know you could take a
whole freeway
yeah the b sharp thick way yeah
you go down that one-on-one you talking
about shops out y'all took shop south
man the traffic's crazy
yeah traffic fit the traffic's crazy
there's just taco trucks everywhere
it's just ten lanes across it doesn't
get you anywhere
it's just this you're going to circle
it's like a nascar track
[Music]